♪ ♪
>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING AND
WELCOME TO
"TUCKER CARLSON TONIGHT."
OUR CAPITAL CITY WASHINGTON IS
UNDER MILITARY OCCUPATION
TONIGHT.
VIA OF INAUGURATION DAY, THERE
ARE EXPECTED TO BE OVER 26,000
ARMED FEDERAL TROOPS IN
WASHINGTON.
NO LIVING AMERICAN HAS SEEN A
MOMENT LIKE WE ARE WATCHING NOW.
26,000 SOLDIERS.
THAT’S MORE THAN FIVE TIMES THE
NUMBER OF AMERICAN MILITARY
PERSONNEL CURRENTLY STATIONED IN
IRAQ AND AFGHANISTAN COMBINED.
THAT IS MORE THAN TWICE THE
NUMBER OF TROOPS THAT
PRESIDENT LYNDON JOHNSON ORDERED
TO WASHINGTON IN 1968.
IN APRIL OF 1968,
WASHINGTON, D.C.,
WASHINGTON, D.C., WAS LITERALLY
ON FIRE.
POLICE RIOTS HAD BROKEN OUT
AFTER THE ASSASSINATION OF
MARTIN LUTHER KING.
HIS MEMORY WE CELEBRATE TODAY.
AT LEAST 13 OF THEM DIED.
MUCH OF THE CAPITAL WAS LEVELED
AND IT STAYED THAT WAY.
BLOCKS OF TROUBLE FOR DECADES.
IF YOU WERE IN WASHINGTON IN THE
1990s, YOU REMEMBER WHAT IT
LOOKS LIKE.
THE INTERACTION OF JANUARY 6TH
WAS MUCH WORSE THAN ANY OF THAT.
A POLICE OFFICER WAS HIT IN THE
HEAD BY RIDERS, THEN LATER HAD A
STROKE AND DIED AT A LOCAL
HOSPITAL.
AN UNARMED PROTESTER WAS SHOT BY
AUTHORITIES.
A WOMAN MAY HAVE BEEN TRAMPLED
TO DEATH BY THE CROWD.
AS OF TONIGHT, THOSE ARE THE
THREE CASUALTIES WE CAN CONFIRM
FROM THE RIOT CAPITOL BUILDING
ON JANUARY 6TH.
IN RESPONSE TO THAT, OUR LEADERS
HAVE ASSEMBLED THE LARGEST
MILITARY PRESENCE IN WASHINGTON
IN ALL OF AMERICAN HISTORY.
IN 1864 AS THE CIVIL WAR RAGED
ON THE OTHER SIDE, AMERICANS
DIED EVERY DAY IN LARGE NUMBERS
IN BATTLE.
THERE WERE FEWER FEDERAL TROOPS
PROTECTING WASHINGTON, D.C.,
THAN THERE ARE TONIGHT.
AND IT’S TRULY A NATIONAL
FOREST.
THE GUARDSMEN YOU SEE IN
WASHINGTON COME FROM EVERY STATE
AS WELL AS FROM PUERTO RICO AND
THE QUESTION IS WHY IS THAT?
THERE IS NO PRACTICAL OR
OPERATIONAL JUSTIFICATION FOR
IT.
FOR DECADES, WASHINGTON, D.C.,
HAS HAD THE HIGHEST
LAW ENFORCEMENT PRESENCE IN THE
COUNTRY, ONE OF THE HIGHEST IN
THE WORLD.
SO THERE WAS NO NEED TO FLY IN
TROOPS FROM ALASKA TO KEEP THE
CITY SAFE.
BUT KEEPING THE CITY SAFE WAS
HARDLY THE POINT OF THE
EXERCISE.
THE MURDER RATE IN THE DISTRICT
OF COLUMBIA HAS RISEN TO A
TERRIFYING SPEED.
MEN, WOMEN, AND CHILDREN SHOT TO
DEATH IN THE STREETS.
BUT NO ONE IN CHARGE SEEMS TO
CARE ABOUT THAT OR EVEN NOTICE
THEIR DEATHS.
SO NO MATTER WHAT THEY ARE
TELLING YOU, THOSE 26,000 TROOPS
ARE NOT THERE FOR YOUR SAFETY.
INSTEAD, UNMISTAKABLY, THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY IS USING THOSE
TROOPS TO SEND THE REST OF US A
MESSAGE ABOUT POWER.
WE ARE IN CHARGE NOW.
WE RUN THIS NATION FROM HOLLOW
LUKE TO OUR COLONY IN THE
CARIBBEAN AND EVERYTHING IN
BETWEEN.
DO NOT QUESTION US.
MEN WITH GUNS AND FORCE ARE
DECREASED.
WE CONTROL THE PENTAGON.
AND INDEED THEY DO CONTROL THE
PENTAGON.
REPUBLICANS HAVE SPENT YEARS
IGNORING THE LEFTWARD DRIFT.
BUT WE CAN’T IGNORE IT NOW.
THE MASK IS OFF.
ARMED MILITARY LEADERSHIP ARE
THE VERY SAME WHO HOWLED AT THE
IDEA OF DEPLOYING TROOPS.
THOSE SAME GENERALS SENT TENS OF
THOUSANDS OF SOLDIERS WITH
RIFLES TO WASHINGTON.
CLEARLY ON BEHALF OF THE
POLITICAL PARTY THEY SUPPORT.
THEY THEN ALLOWED DEMOCRATIC
POLITICIANS TO DEGRADE AND
POLITICIZE THE MILITARY ITSELF.
DEMOCRATS IN CONGRESS DEMANDED
THAT THEY SUBMIT TO A POLITICAL
PURITY TEST, IDEOLOGICAL VETTING
AS THEY PUT IT TO MAKE SURE THAT
EVERY SOLDIER EXPRESSED LAWYER
TO YOU TO THE REGIME.
NOT LOYAL TO THE TO THE COUNTRY,
NOT TO THE CONSTITUTION BUT
LOYALTY TO THE AIMS OF A
SPECIFIC POLITICAL PARTY.
NOTHING LIKE THAT HAS EVER
HAPPENED IN AMERICA.
JUST A FEW MONTHS AGO, IT WOULD
HAVE BEEN UNIMAGINABLE.
HERE’S CONGRESSMAN STEVE COHEN
OF MEMPHIS EXPLAINING WHY THAT
IS.
>> THE GUARD IS 95% BELIEVE
MALE.
ONLY ABOUT 20% WHITE MALES VOTED
FOR BIDEN.
YOU’VE GOT TO FIGURE THAT AS A
GUARD WHICH IS PREDOMINANTLY
MORE CONSERVATIVE AND I SEE IT
ON MY SOCIAL MEDIA, THEY ARE
PROBABLY NOT MORE THAN 25% OF
THE PEOPLE THAT ARE PROTECTING
US.
THE OTHER 75% ARE IN THE CLASS
THAT WOULD BE THE LARGE CLASS OF
FOLKS THAT MIGHT WANT TO DO
SOMETHING.
>> Tucker: WE SHOULD PAUSE
THAT TAPE AND WE SHOULD CONSIDER
FOR A MOMENT AND THINK DEEPLY
ABOUT WHAT CONGRESSMAN JUST TOLD
US ON TELEVISION.
HE SAID THAT EVERY WHITE MAN IN
THIS COUNTRY IS A POTENTIAL
MURDERER.
EVERY WHITE MAN IN AMERICA
SHOULD BE UNDER SUSPICION PURELY
ON THE BASIS OF BEING WHITE AND
MALE OF PLANNING A PRESIDENTIAL
ASSASSINATION.
HE SAYS WHITE MALE NATIONAL
GUARDSMEN MUST UNDERGO
GOVERNMENT BACKGROUND CHECKS TO
PROVE THEY ARE NOT PLANNING A
MURDER.
HE JUST SAID IT.
THE CNN ANCHOR NODDED AS HE DID.
THE RULES ON GENERALIZATIONS
LIKE THIS HAVE CHANGED QUITE A
BIT IN A VERY SHORT TIME.
IT WASN’T THAT LONG AGO,
NOVEMBER 5TH 2009 THAT AN ARMY
MAJOR OPEN FIRE ON INNOCENT
PEOPLE AT A MILITARY BASE IN
TEXAS.
NOT ALL THE SUN SHOT 45 PEOPLE.
IT EMERGED THAT HE WAS AN
ISLAMIC EXTREMIST AND THEY HAD
FAILED TO PROTECT THE PUBLIC.
THEY KNEW THAT THE PENTAGON WAS
COURT-MARTIALED.
INSTEAD, MONTHS OF LECTURES
ABOUT HOW HE HAD NO RIGHT TO
COME TO BROADER CONCLUSIONS
ABOUT WHAT HAD HAPPENED AT
FORT HOOD.
YES, THE SHOOTINGS WERE BAD BUT
NOT BARACK OBAMA MADE CLEAR AT
THE TIME AN ACT OF TERRORISM.
IT WOULD BE THE SIN OF DRAWING
ANY CONNECTION BETWEEN HIS
BELIEFS AND THE BELIEFS OF
ANYONE ELSE IN OUR COUNTRY.
NADAL WAS NOT A STAND-IN FOR ALL
MUSLIMS SALSA WITH YOUR
PREJUDICE.
THAT’S WHAT THEY TOLD US.
MOST AMERICANS ARE DECENT
PEOPLE.
THEY DON’T BLAME ENTIRE GROUPS
FOR THEIR CRIMES.
BIGOTRY IS IMMORAL AND SO IS
COLLECTIVE PUNISHMENT.
THERE IS NOTHING MORE
UN-AMERICAN THAN THAT.
COLLECTIVE PUNISHMENT IS NOW THE
OFFICIAL POLICY OF COLLECTIVE
PUNISHMENT BY THE PENTAGON.
SINCE WE HAVE ESTABLISHED THIS
NEW STAND IT’S REQUIREMENT OF
COLLECTIVE PUNISHMENT, WHAT
OTHER GROUPS OF AMERICANS SHOULD
BE DENOUNCED AND HURT SIMPLY
BECAUSE OF THE WAY THEY LOOK
SIMPLY BECAUSE OF THE DNA THEY
WERE BORN WITH?
OR DOES THIS APPLY ONLY TO WHITE
MEN?
AND IF IT DOES APPLY
SPECIFICALLY TO WHITE MEN WHICH
IS DEFINITELY THE IMPRESSION WE
ARE GETTING, HOW DOES IT
CONTRIBUTE TO YOUR STATED GOAL
OF REDUCING WHITE MALE
EXTREMISM?
BECAUSE DOESN’T ATTACKING PEOPLE
ON THE BASIS OF QUALITIES THEY
CAN’T CONTROL MAKE THEM MORE IT
EXTREME NOT LESS EXTREME?
SINCE YOU ARE NOT A, ONE AND ALL
OF THAT BE OBVIOUS TO YOU?
SO WHY ARE YOU DOING?
WHY IN THE NAME OF FIGHTING
EXTREMISM ARE YOU, CONGRESSMAN:
CREATING IT?
BY THE WAY, DEAD CERTAIN, NO
QUESTION ABOUT IT, THAT’S
EXACTLY WHAT YOU ARE DOING.
WHAT IS YOUR MOTIVE FOR DOING
THAT?
THAT’S A SINCERE QUESTION BY THE
WAY.
CONGRESSMAN COHEN IS INVITED ON
THE SHOW ANYTIME TO GIVE AN
ANSWER.
IN THE MEANTIME, YOU’VE GOT TO
WONDER ABOUT WHAT THE GUARDSMEN
THEMSELVES THINK ABOUT THESE NEW
POLICIES.
SERVING IN THE NATIONAL GUARD IS
NOT EASY WORK ALTHOUGH THEY ARE
NOT PAID MUCH.
SOME, YOU’VE GOT TO IMAGINE HER
DOING IT FOR LOVE OF COUNTRY.
NOW THEY’VE BEEN DEPLOYED TO
THEIR COUNTRY’S CITY AND GIVEN
ORDERS.
THEY’VE BEEN TOLD IF THEY WERE
BORN A CERTAIN WAY AND THEY ARE
WHITE AND MALE AND EVIL AND
DANGEROUS, THEY THEMSELVES ARE
UNDER SUSPICION FOR BEING THE
ENEMY.
THEY ARE POTENTIAL KILLERS,
ASSASSINS, BETRAYERS OF A
NATION.
WE ARE NOT OVERSTATING THIS.
HERE IS A NATIONAL GUARD
COMMANDER.
THEY ARE WHITE NATIONALISTS, HE
TELLS THEM.
[SPANISH]SPEAKING SPANISH]
>> Tucker: IF YOU WANTED IN A
REPUTABLE --
YOU WOULD SAY THEY MIGHT HAVE TO
SHOOT PEOPLE WHO VOTED FOR THE
WRONG CANDIDATE IN THE LAST
ELECTION.
YOU CAN SEE WHERE THIS WOULD ALL
GO.
IT’S REALLY SCARY.
SO WHERE IS THE PUSHBACK OF
DEFENDERS?
WE’VE BEEN GETTING CALLS TODAY
FROM REPUBLICAN SENATORS BEGGING
TO TALK ABOUT THE PUSHBACK
AGAINST IT.
HE IS USING THE MILITARY OF THE
UNITED STATES AND USING IT AS A
POLITICAL WEAPON.
YOU THINK THE PENTAGON WOULD BE
OUTRAGED BY THIS.
IT IS SUCH A TOTAL BETRAYAL OF
EVERYTHING WE ARE SUPPOSED TO
STAND FOR.
NOT A SINGLE OFFICER HAS
RESIGNED IN PROTEST.
BACKGROUND CHECKS ON PEOPLE
BECAUSE OF THEIR RACE AND SEX,
BECAUSE OF THEIR POLITICAL
REVIEWS.
VIEWS.
"I WAS CHIEF PROSECUTOR AT
GUANTANAMO FOR OVER TWO YEARS, A
FORMER AIR FORCE PRO SET ON
TWITTER TODAY AND THERE IS FAR
MORE EVIDENCE.
IT IS TIME WE START A DOMESTIC
WAR ON SEDITION BY AMERICAN
TERRORISTS.
THAT’S A VERBATIM QUOTE.
I WILL REPEAT THAT SENTENCE IN
CASE YOU THOUGHT YOU HEARD IT
INCORRECTLY.
A CAREER MILITARY OFFICER HAS
NOW CALLED FOR A DOMESTIC WAR ON
SEDITION BY AMERICAN TERRORISTS.
A WAR.
AMONG THOSE TERRORISTS, THE ONE
HE SAYS ARE LITERALLY MORE
DANGEROUS THAN AL QAEDA AND
SHOULD BE IN PRISON IS A
25-YEAR-OLD WEIRD WEIRD WHEELCHA
MUST BE SUBDUED BY FORCE.
THEY ARE THE ENEMY OUR MILITARY
EXISTS TO FIGHT.
NOW KEEP IN MIND THAT DAVIS
SPENT HIS LIFE UNDER ARMS.
YOU CAN BE CERTAIN HE’S NOT
USING THE TERM ENEMY IN SOME
METAPHORICAL SENSE.
HE MEANS ENEMY IN THE WAY USAMA
BIN LADEN IS AN ENEMY.
REMEMBER WHAT WE DID TO USAMA
BIN LADEN.
HAS TWITTER SEEN HIS TWEET?
DO THEY CARE?
DOES ANYBODY?
YOU KNOW THE ANSWER.
NOT A SINGLE ONE DENOUNCED WHAT
HE SAID OR EVEN TOLD HIM TO COOL
IT A LITTLE BIT.
AND WHAT ABOUT THE NEWS MEDIA?
REPORTERS SEARCH FOR WHAT THEY
CALL EXTREMISM.
HAVE THEY NOTICED DAVIS ON
TWITTER?
PROBABLY THEY HAVE BUT OF COURSE
THEY AGREE WITH HIM.
JUST INCOME OF
"THE DAILY BEAST," THE HOME PAGE
OF OUR --
HE RAN A PIECE WITH THIS TITLE.
OTHER COUNTRIES, THE STORY
POINTED OUT, HAVE DOMESTIC SPY
AGENCIES TO FIGHT EXTREMISTS AT
HOME.
WHAT THE PIECE DOES NOT MENTION
IS ALSO OTHER COUNTRIES WOULD
INCLUDE CHINA, NORTH KOREA
NORTH KOREA, KAZAKHSTAN.
DOMESTIC SPY AGENCY IS A NOT
VERY SOLID EUPHEMISM FOR SECRET
POLICE.
THAT’S WHAT THEY ARE CALLING
FOR.
NOW YOU’D THINK TALK LIKE THAT
WOULD CONSTITUTE A BIG RED WINE
FOR THE MANY PROFESSIONAL
FREEDOM DEFENDERS IN WASHINGTON,
THE ONES YOU SEND MONEY TO,
THINK TAKES.
THEY ARE EVERYWHERE BUT NOT
TONIGHT.
WHERE ARE THEY TONIGHT?
A FORMER U.S. MILITARY OFFICER
DECLARES WAR ON AN AMERICAN
CITIZEN.
MEMBERS OF THE MEDIA CALL FOR A
SECRET POLICE AGENCY.
THIS IS THE STUFF OF LIBERTARIAN
NIGHTMARES.
IT’S WHAT THEY CLAIM TO HATE.
SO WHERE ARE THEY NOW?
WHY ISN’T CHARLES KOCH’S
SPENDING BILLIONS OF $ TO STOP
THIS?
THESE UNPRECEDENTED ATTACKS ON
LIBERTY.
HE’S DEFINITELY NOT SPENDING
BILLIONS HERE AND HE BEEN DOING
ANYTHING.
AND SO IT CONTINUES.
DEMOCRATS IN CONGRESS SUPPORT A
NEW SECRET POLICE AGENCY?
WHAT BETTER WAY TO PROTECT YOUR
OWN POWER?
THOSE EXTREMISTS NEEDLESS TO SAY
WOULD BE A POLITICAL OPPONENT.
SO YOU DON’T HAVE TO WORRY ABOUT
THEM ANYMORE BECAUSE THEY WILL
BE IN JAIL.
JUST LAST YEAR, SCHNEIDER
SPONSORED LEGISLATION TO BEGIN
THE PROCESS OF CREATING JUST
SUCH AN AGENCY.
SPYING ON AMERICANS BASED ON
THEIR POLITICAL BELIEFS.
AND GUESS WHAT?
ALL BUT TWO REPUBLICANS.
PURCHASE, OWNERSHIP, OR
POSSESSION OF BODY ARMOR.
BODY ARMOR.
NOT THE OWNERSHIP OF GUNS,
BOMBS, OR EVEN KNIVES.
JUST INTRODUCED LEGISLATION IN
ORDER TO OWN AMMUNITION.
THAT SEEMS EXTREME ESPECIALLY
FROM NO, IT’S MUCH CRAZIER THAN
THAT.
IT’S BANNING BODY ARMOR.
DOES ICES THAT CANNOT UNDER ANY
CIRCUMSTANCES BE USED TO HURT
ANOTHER PERSON.
BODY ARMOR IS PURELY DEFENSIVE.
BODY ARMOR EXISTS ONLY TO
PROTECT THE PERSON WHO WAS
WEARING THE BODY ARMOR.
IT IS ALREADY A CRIME TO USE
BODY ARMOR IN MOST PLACES WHILE
COMMITTING A VIOLENT FELONY.
THIS IS DIFFERENT.
THIS WOULD MAKE IT A CRIME TO
POSSESS BODY ARMOR AT ALL.
WHY WOULD YOU DO THAT?
WHY WOULD YOU MAKE IT A CRIME TO
POSSESS SOMETHING THEY COULD
SAVE YOUR LIFE?
IT’S LIKE BANNING SEAT BELTS OR
BANNING HELMETS.
AND ACTUALLY NOW THAT YOU
MENTION IT, HIS BILL WOULD BAN
HELMETS, ANY HELMET THAT WOULD
PROTECT YOU FROM GUNFIRE.
FOR REAL.
AND HONESTLY YOU SHOULD PAUSE
WHEN YOU HEAR THAT.
WHAT COULD POSSIBLY BE THE
MOTIVE FOR IT?
WE CAN’T THINK OF A NONSINISTER
EXPLANATION FOR BANNING BODY
ARMOR.
IT SHOULD MAKE YOU NEAREST NERVO
REPUBLICANS HAVEN’T SAID A WORD
ABOUT THIS.
THEY ARE TOO BUSY WITH AGREEING
WITH DEMOCRATS.
SOMEHOW THAT IS NOT RACIST.
HOW IS THAT RACIST EXACTLY?
WE’LL TELL YOU EXACTLY THE
TRUTH.
WHAT HAPPENED ON JANUARY 6TH WAS
AWFUL.
WE DON’T LIKE MOBS.
WE DON’T LIKE VANDALISM.
WE DON’T LIKE VIOLENCE.
WE SET IT AT THE TIME.
WE’LL SEE SAY IT AGAIN NOW.
WE WILL NEVER STOP SAYING IT.
WHAT HAPPENED ON JANUARY SIXTH
WAS NOT AN INSURRECTION.
IT WAS TOLD AND REPEATED PURELY
FOR POLITICAL REASONS.
HERE IS WHAT IT ACTUALLY LOOKED
LIKE INSIDE THE CAPITAL.
[BLEEP] HEY MAN.
GOOD TO SEE YOU GUYS.
MEDICAL ATTENTION?
THE GOING GOOD.
[INAUDIBLE]
>> I GOT SHOT IN THE FACE WAS
SOME KIND OF PLASTIC BULLET.
I’VE GOT TO MAKE SURE I’M NOT
DISRESPECTING THE PLACE.
>> Tucker: JUST CHATTING WITH
THE COPS ON THE HOUSE FLOOR.
THEY GUY IN THE VIKING HAT IS A
REAL-LIFE PERSON.
HIS NAME IS JACOB.
HE IS BEING HELD WITHOUT BAIL.
THE JUDGE WHO ORDERED HIM TO ROT
IN JAIL PRESENTED NO EVIDENCE
THAT HE WAS VIOLENT OR A THREAT
TO ANYONE.
NEVERTHELESS, THE JUDGE
CONCLUDED "THIS IS AN
INSURRECTION AND HE WAS A SYMBOL
OF WHAT OCCURRED."
HE NOW FACES 25 YEARS OR MORE IN
PRISON IF CONVICTED.
YOU JUST SAW THE CRIME.
THE REAL CRIME THOUGH WAS BEING
A SYMBOL OF INSURRECTION.
NO MATTER WHAT HAPPENS, HE WILL
ALMOST CERTAINLY DO MORE TIME IN
PRISON THAN COUNTLESS
MURDERERS,, AND ARMED ROBBERS.
SINCE MEMORIAL DAY, ABOUT 90% OF
THE PEOPLE ARRESTED HAVE BEEN
RELEASED BACK ONTO THE STREETS
FREE TO DO IT AGAIN.
GUN CRIME?
REALLY.
FROM A PARTY THAT IS AGAINST GUN
CRIME.
GUN CRIME.
90%.
UNLIKE JACOB, THEY ARE NOT
SYMBOLS OF INSURRECTION.
YOU KNOW WHAT ELSE IS NOT A
SYMBOL OF INSURRECTION?
THESE PEOPLE.
[SCREAMS]
[HORN SOUNDING]
[BLEEP]
>> Tucker: THAT WAS YOUR
COUNTRY FOR MONTHS AND MONTHS ON
END.
WE ARE PRETENDING NONE OF THAT
HAPPEN BUT IT DID HAPPEN.
MOBS OF POLITICIZED THUGS, EVERY
ONE OF THEM SUPPORTED THE
VIOLENT OVERTHROW OF THE ELECTED
PRESIDENT AND SAID SO LOUDLY
EVERY OPPORTUNITY.
IT’S REPEATED ON BUILDINGS.
THEY WENT ON TO TORCH, LOOT, AND
VANDALIZE MAJOR AMERICAN CITIES.
IN THE CITY OF MINNEAPOLIS
ALONE, AND T4 RIOTERS BURNED AND
DESTROYED MORE THAN 700
BUILDINGS.
HOW MANY INNOCENT PEOPLE DID
THEY KILL?
WE HAVE COUNTED OVER TWO DOZEN
NATIONWIDE NOT INCLUDING AS MANY
HUNDREDS BY CRIMINALS WHO WERE
SPRUNG FROM LOCKUP.
WE DON’T KNOW THE FULL DEATH
TOLL.
PROBABLY WILL NEVER KNOW.
NOBODY IS KEEPING TRACK.
THERE IS NO POLITICAL ADVANTAGE.
BUT IT’S NOT A PROBLEM BECAUSE
NONE OF THAT WAS INSURRECTION.
NOT EVEN SYMBOLICALLY.
SO HOW LONG WILL THIS CYCLE GO
ON?
IF YOU ARE HOPING AMERICA WILL
REVERT TO NORMAL ON WEDNESDAY
AFTERNOON AFTER JOE BIDEN IS
SWORN IN AS PRESIDENT, YOU
PROBABLY ASSUME THAT QUARANTINES
AND MANDATORY FACE COVERINGS ARE
TEMPORARY TOO.
PROBABLY NOT.
SOMETHING AWFUL HAS BEEN
UNLEASHED ON OUR COUNTRY.
UNCHECKED IT WILL INEVITABLY
LEAD TO MORE AWFUL THINGS.
EVERY ACTION PROVOKES A
REACTION.
THAT IS PHYSICS.
IT’S ALSO HUMAN NATURE.
ABRAHAM LINCOLN UNDERSTOOD THIS
WELL.
IN JANUARY OF 1838, LINCOLN
SPOKE TO AN AUDIENCE IN
SPRINGFIELD, ILLINOIS, ABOUT
WHAT HAPPENS WHEN A SOCIETY
REFUSES TO PUNISH THUGS AND
VANDALS.
IT’S NOT A SMALL THING.
CITIZENS, LINCOLN SAID, SEE
THEIR PROPERTY DESTROYED, THEIR
FAMILIES INSULTED AND THEIR
LIVES IN DANGER.
AND THEY SEE NOTHING IN PROSPECT
THAT PROVIDES DUMB EYE FOR BOTH
THE CHANGE FOR THE BETTER.
TO BECOME TIRED OF AND DISGUSTED
WITH A GOVERNMENT THAT OFFERS
THEM NO PROTECTION.
AT THAT POINT, LINCOLN NOTED,
THEY BECOME RADICAL.
THEY DO THINGS THEY NEVER WOULD
HAVE CONSIDERED IF THE
AUTHORITIES HAD BOTHERED TO
ENFORCE THE LAWS THEY MADE IN
THE FIRST PLACE.
IN OTHER WORDS, THEY BECOME
LIABLE TO SHOW UP AT THE CAPITOL
BUILDING IN VIKING HATS AND FACE
PAINT.
YOU COULD HAVE SCRIPTED WHAT WAS
GOING TO HAPPEN ON JANUARY 5TH.
WHAT WE CAN’T KNOW IS WHAT
HAPPENS NOW.
AND LET’S PRAY THAT THE PEOPLE
PLANNING A WAR ON AMERICAN
CITIZENS FIND THEIR REASON AND
THEIR DECENCY AND STOP TALKING
LIKE THAT IMMEDIATELY MUCH LESS
PLANNING TO ACT ON IT.
LET’S HOPE THE BIDEN CAMPAIGN
DIDN’T REALLY MEAN WHEN THEY
PROMISED TO MAKE "THE SAME
COMMITMENT TO ROOT OUT DOMESTIC
TERRORISM AS THEY HAVE TO
STOPPING INTERNATIONAL TERRORISM
TERRORISM.
THE TRUTH IS WE DON’T DESERVE
THAT.
VERY FEW AMERICANS DESERVE TO BE
TREATED LIKE USAMA BIN LADEN
BECAUSE THEY ARE NOT TERRORISTS.
THEY SHOULDN’T BE TREATED LIKE
ISIS.
EVEN IF YOU HATE HOW THEY VOTED,
WE DON’T NEED A WAR WITHIN OUR
BORDERS.
STOP CALLING FOR ONE, PEOPLE IN
CHARGE.
ONLY THE WORST PEOPLE WILL WIN
THAT WAR.
HE WAS MAY BE THE ONLY TRUE
ECONOMIC POPULIST EVER ELECTED
TO THE UNITED STATES SENATE.
HE WAS A DEMOCRAT BACK IN THE
TIME WHEN YOU COULD BE A
POPULIST AND STILL A DEMOCRAT.
HE WAS MORE HATED THAN
DONALD TRUMP EVER IMAGINED HE
COULD BE HATED BY EVERYONE.
NOT JUST REPUBLICANS, BUT
FRANKLIN ROOSEVELT.
HE WAS A VERY FLAWED GUY.
THEY ALWAYS ARE.
BUT HE WASN’T STUPID.
IN FACT HE HAD FLASHES OF
WISDOM.
IN 1935, HE HAD A FLASH OF
HERE’S WHAT HE HE SAID.
"IF THE UNITED STATES EVER ENDS
UP WITH A FASCIST GOVERNMENT, WE